[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait choper
vous par votre mère ou un truc comme ça
en train de faire un truc dans votre
chambre dit la vérité franchement rim k
way dit la vérité
accroché par la fenêtre train de fumer
par la tête attention on ne fait pas ça
rime cas tu t'es fait défoncer salma est
forcément mauvais choix tu as pris une
claire ah ouais quoi vous est-ce que
capucine way en train de faire l'amour
non ouais quoi coq est rentré votre père
ou votre père mon père non voilà vous
étiez en train de faire l'amour avec le
fils de qui
vous étiez en train de faire l'amour
avec lui
alors aux sports hamane d'une carrière
dans cette émission une personne mais
pas à sa carrière
voilà aujourd'hui c'est capital oui
enfin voila c'était un peu gênant et je
faisais quand tu m'étonnes c'était il ya
quatre ans je crois et je lui ai fait
croire qu'il me faisait juste un massage
bah oui oui il a connu la crue ah ben on
était sous la couette quand même non ah
ouais il est en train de bas-warneton le
bouche à oreille vous ai dit quoi m'a
dit vous faites quoi la jib à orange la
chambre disais rien on se masse et on se
masse et où ça vous est déjà isabelle
non moi j'ai jamais été surprise je
t'aimerai j'avais fait un nom dans moi
j'ai vraiment craint de faire du tricot
dans la chambre j'ai jamais su faire ça
alors mais en revanche moi non mais
parce que les trucs où je me suis fait
violer c'est que moi je vis des tous les
paquets de biscuits mais j'ai tournés de
l'autre côté pour ça se voit pas et un
jour on a eu du monde dans la maison et
ma mère a voulu sortir un truc y avait
plus rien tous les trucs était vide et
tournée du de leur côté une autre
anecdote je peux pas terminer la fumeuse
cette séquence oui c'est le léger la
version surpris par mon père en train
d'initier mon chien colpaert besoin tout
seul mais j'aime mon chien j'avais un
chien au caire non mais karen sala
j'avais mon chien un cocker america et
pour vieux ils sortaient jamais il était
toujours chez moi et du coup j'avais
notre pôle cabin kitchen ça sympa je me
suis avec la race et du coup je me suis
mis dans l'idée née des maîtres ensemble
parce que mon cher il dit il était
dépressif louis personnes --dont du coup
je vais amener la petite chienne dans la
chambre avec mon copain et j'ai essayé
d'inciter monk au caire et dont coca et
voulait rien faire donc je le mettais
carrément dessus sur la chaîne comme ça
je donnais des klaxons
là jamais rien
ailleurs on respecte les animaux à jean
michel maire j'ai voulu apporter du
bonheur vous êtes fous bah bravo un
moment super d'autres émissions et à
d'autres trucs ou un autre chose un
rapide
non merci à l'état mais raymond cocker
année j'ai alors réalisé à lyon j'avais
fait croire à ma mère je voulais voir ce
que c'était que les magazines de cul
donc j'avais acheté toute une série de
magazines de cul quand ma mère m'a
surprise dans la chambre j'ai dit c'est
la maîtresse d'école qui veut qu'on
fasse un devoir sur le comparatif des
magazines qui sont pas de notre âge et
ma mère est allée voir l'institutrice
dans le mur en eirl madonna les obliger
à faire des trucs comme ça et donc du
coup j'ai été punie trois mois de
sorties et de quoi que ce soit à l'écart
des combats
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]